iraqis have been waiting for a change
taxi drivers are no exception
they say the recent unrest has worsened
an already overstretched transportation
system
are so crowded so jammed our work has
been affected we spend long hours to get
a few passengers with this crisis men
are reluctant to travel to baghdad
most of the roads are blocked because of
the security measures imposed following
the demonstrations we have to make turns
that take hours within
iraq's political system is in crisis
there hasn't been a government for nine
months
parliament has been occupied by
supporters of influential shia leader
mukhtar
he and his backers reject the nomination
of muhammad sudhani for prime minister
and those who support the rival the
coordination framework have staged
counter protests
eventually what sudden did is that he
actually provoked the coordination frame
by saying okay i want i want to change
the whole political process
so what the coordination frame is that
made demonstrations
and show this address
is that we are capable
to go to the edge
so that means eventually there will be
negotiations so that's it it's
eventually a political game it's not
really
going forward for some sort of reform
for the whole political process
this political standoff has disrupted
work across several state institutions
iraqis are facing scorching summer
temperatures and possibly weeks of
political unrest
many have been hoping for a new
government that can enhance services
and improve their lives
although it's an oil-rich country iraq
remains one of the least developed
nations in the world
poverty and unemployment are on the rise
we count on new authorities to create
jobs we need jobs we have been waiting
for so long
people here were hopeful for a change
especially after last october's
elections but recent events have
overshadowed those hopes
al jazeera baghdad